>>Mark Hoppus: Hello.
It's me, Mark Hoppus, shooting this video
out from the Blink 182 tour.
I'll be doing an exclusive interview right
here on YouTube.
Tom will be joining me for a conversation
on Google+.
We wanna get questions from you so we can
answer them during the chat.
Anything you're dying to know about Blink
182 so we can answer them, well, here's your
chance to ask.
Submit a question or video on YouTube dot
com forward slash @GoogleTalks.
And while you're there, you can vote on the
questions you'd most want us to answer.
You have until the end of day on Tuesday,
October 4th to ask.
So what are you waiting for?
I'll see you back here very soon.
Tune into our live stream on Wednesday, October
5th from three to four PM, Pacific Coast Time.
Maybe even Qui will be there.